In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for June 1st, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Justin, the philosopher, and his companions.
On the first of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Justin, the philosopher,
and of his companions, Caritan, Carita, Elipistus, Irax, Paon, and Liberian.
St. Justin was born in the first years of the 2nd century in Flavia, Neopolis, now Nablus.
A town founded on the site of the Biblical Shechem after the taking of Jerusalem by the Romans.
Of an affluent pagan family, he received a select education and nourishing an ardent
desire for the truth, frequented various philosophers, but he encountered nothing but deception,
finding that they could teach him nothing about God.
He finally attached himself to a famous platenist who was able to give wings to his spirit through
reflection on ideas and on the spiritual world evoked by Plato.
After a short time, believing that he had become wise and hoping to see God at once, as
the philosopher had promised him, he withdrew to a solitary and silent spot by the sea to
give himself to meditation.
While he was walking on the shore deep in reflection, an old man with a venerable and
majestic mean, both gentle and grave, appeared in front of him.
They talked together, and Justin praised philosophy to him as being the greatest and most precious
activity in comparison with which all other human action is negligible.
The old man then asked him how philosophers could find for themselves a true idea of God
when they had no living experience of him.
When Justin replied that the intellect can see God, the elder said, only he who is clothed
with the Holy Spirit receives this power after having been purified by the practice of the virtues.
He also refuted the platonic doctrines of the soul and reincarnation, and showed him that
one could not reasonably maintain that the world is eternal and uncreated, as God alone
is engendered and incorruptible, perfectly one and ever equal to himself.
As for the soul, contrary to Plato's opinion, it has no life in itself but lives because
it participates in the life given by God.
Justin exalted by these words, asked him to which masters he should go to learn this truth
unknown to the sages of old.
The old man replied that this doctrine is that of great men, more ancient than the philosophers,
righteous men, and dear to God, who spoke by the Holy Spirit and gave oracles about
the future that are now fulfilled.
They are known as the prophets, filled with the Holy Spirit.
They only speak and proclaimed that which they had seen and heard, having no recourse to
subtle demonstrations.
Witnesses of the truth, they glorified the one God and Father, and proclaimed through signs
and writings the Christ, who was to come from Him.
He finished by saying, and you, pray above all that the doors of light be opened to you.
For no one can see and understand unless God and His Christ give Him understanding.
As soon as the old man had gone away, a fire was lit in the soul of the young philosopher
these prophets and wise men, friends of Christ.
Reflecting on the words that he had just heard, he realized that this doctrine is the only
true philosophy that is profitable to the soul, and decided to join Christ's disciples, whom
he had long admired for their scorning of torture and death.
After his baptism, he studied the holy scriptures in Palestine, and then, without leaving aside
his cloak and beard, the distinctive marks of the philosopher, he went to teach this true
philosophy of the prophets and apostles in Asia Minor.
In about one thirty-six, when a Jewish uprising was cruelly put down by the Romans in Palestine,
he met a well-known rabbi called Trifon, with whom he talked for two days.
Christen showed him with many quotations from the scriptures that the law and the whole Old
Testament were only a preparation and a unique and coherent figure of Christ, the Son of God,
the true logiver of the new covenant proclaimed by the prophets, which supersedes the Old.
It is now the converted nations who constitute the true spiritual Israel,
and are called to become gods by the grace of the Holy Spirit.
Continuing his travels, Justin made two long stays in Rome and settled in a house near the
Thermy of Timothy, where he taught the doctrine of the truth to those who came to him.
For him, the philosopher become Christian, the word of God revealed in the gospel
represented not only the fulfillment of the prophets' oracles, but was also the truth
glimpsed by wise men and pagan philosophers. Giving human reason its rights, he underlined its
limits and taught that it is the same word of God that both inspired the prophets and is also
present as the seed of all human knowledge, spermaticos logos, all that is said of him,
by whom so ever belongs to us Christians. For all the writers have caught an obscure glimpse
of the truth through the seed of the word within them, but it is another matter to possess a seed
and a resemblance proportionate to his faculties, and yet another to grasp the object itself,
of which the participation and imitation proceed from the grace that comes from him.
From his school of philosophy which had become a church, where he gathered together with the
friends of true wisdom, Justin also battled for the confirmation of the true faith with regard to
the heretics, those wolves disguised as lambs, who passed as Christians, teaching the most absurd
doctrines. But it was preeminently as an apologist of Christianity before the Roman authorities
that Justin became famed. In about 155 he addressed a first Apologia to Emperor Antonius Pius,
in which he refuted the gross calamities that the pagans were spreading about the Christians.
They were not, he said, either atheists or enemies of this state, and their moral conduct was
above reproach, greatly superior to that of the pagans who satiated themselves with the botches.
And after having demonstrated the accord between the intuitions of philosophy and biblical revelation,
he described the nobility and purity of the Eucharistic assemblies in which the common life
centered on the Eucharist is led in mutual assistance and help to the needy.
You can kill us," he wrote, but Harmus, no. Our hope is not in the present time,
and we have no fear of your executioners. We do not hate our accusers, but have pity on them.
Only desiring their conversion. Some years later, in 160, Marcus Aurelius having exceeded to power
took repressive measures against the Christians under the influence of his friends, the philosophers.
A Roman noblewoman who had been converted to Christianity and had renounced her disillute life
under the influence of a certain tolamy attempted to influence her husband, reminding him of the future
punishment reserved for the debauched. When he refused to reform, she demanded a divorce.
He, in a fury, then had told me put in prison. After a long incarceration, he appeared before
the prefect, Urbicus, and confessed his faith. The death sentence was hardly pronounced when a
surgeon Lucius protested out loud at this iniquitous judgment, and confessed that he too was a Christian.
He was arrested together with another Christian, and the three innocent men were executed.
At the same time that this was happening, Justin, sensing that a similar fate was awaiting him,
sent a second Apologria to the Emperor and the Senate, in which he first replied to two
Ironical objections by the pagans, who asked, on the one hand, why Christians did not commit suicide
in order to go to their God the more quickly? And, on the other hand, if this God is indeed all powerful,
why does he let his worshipers be persecuted? Justin explained that it was the rage and jealousy of
the demons that was the cause of the persecution of Christians, and that if there were no truth
or virtue in them, their constancy under torture would be inexplicable. If God delays the catastrophe
that will destroy the world, he added, it is because of the Christians, in whom he sees a reason
for preserving the world. He concluded, I am a Christian, I glory in it, and confess that my whole
desire is to be known as one. Justin had found an implacable adversary in the person of the philosopher
and cynic presence, a depraved and ambitious man, who, seeing the Christian philosophers' success
and fearing to lose his pupils, was incessantly plotting intrigues against him. It is probably as a result
of these machinations that, in about 165 during his second visit to Rome, Justin was arrested on the
orders of the prefect Rousticos, Marcus Aurelius, former tutor, along with six of his disciples,
Caritan, the Virgin Carita, Alapistas, Hyrax, Peon, and Liberian. As soon as they came before the
tribunal, the prefect addressed himself to Justin. Do you submit to the gods and obey the emperor?
No one can be blamed, or condemned for obeying the commandments of our Lord Jesus Christ,
replied the philosopher. When Rousticos asked him to which science he devoted himself, he replied,
I have successfully studied all the sciences. I ended up by embracing the true doctrine of the Christians,
although it is displeasing to those whom error leads astray. He then explained that he taught
nothing of himself, but only that which the inspired prophets proclaimed, and that he freely dispensed
this doctrine to whoever came to seek it where it belonged. His companions having confessed each
in turn that they were Christians, the prefect, turning towards Justin, asked him if he hoped to gain
heaven through the sufferings that were about to be inflicted on him. The philosopher retorted,
I hope if I suffer the torture of which you tell me to receive the recompense destined for those
who keep the commandments of Christ. That is our dearest desire, to suffer for our Lord Jesus Christ
and to be saved, and so we present ourselves assured and at peace, before the terrible judgment seat
of our God and Savior, before whom the whole world must appear. The other martyrs cried out,
do what you will, we are Christians and will not sacrifice to idols. They heard the death sentence
with thanksgiving to God. Then, after having been beaten, consummated their martyrdom by being
beheaded, some of the faithful secretly took their bodies and buried them in a worthy place
through the prayers of our Holy Father's. O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.